Today's lecture is about the portfolio diversification,
uh,
and about,
supporting financial institutions,
notably mutual funds.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it's actually a kind of a crusade of mine.
Uh,
I believe that the world needs more portfolio diversification.
And that might sound to you a little bit
odd,
but I think it's absolutely true that the same kind of cause that Emma Thompson
goes through,
uh,
which is to help poor people of the world.
Uh,
it can be advanced through portfolio diversification.
And I,
I seriously mean that,
that there are a lot of human hardships that can be solved by diversifying
portfolios.
Uh,
so what I'm going to talk about today applies not just to comfortable wealthy
people,
but it applies to everyone.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so it's really about risk when there's a bad outcome for anyone.
That's the outcome of some random draw.
When people get into real trouble,
uh,
in,
in their lives,
it's because of a sequence of bad events that push them into an unfortunate
position.
Very often financial,
uh,
risk management is part of the thing that prevents that from happening.
Okay.
So,
um,
the first,
uh,
let me go to,
I want to start this lecture with some mathematics.
Uh,
and it's a continuation of the second lecture where I talked about,
um,
the principle of,
of,
uh,
of dispersal of risk.
And I want now to carry that forward into something a little bit more focused on
the portfolio problem.
And so I'm going to start this lecture with the big,
a discussion of,
uh,
how one constructs the portfolio and what is the mathematics of it.
And that will lead us into the capital asset pricing model,
uh,
which is the cornerstone of a lot of thinking in finance.
Uh,
and I'm going to go through this rather quickly because there are other courses
yet at,
at Yale that we'll cover this more thoroughly.
Notably,
uh,
John,
John Akopoulos,
econ two 51,
but I think we can get the basic points here.
Uh,
and so let's start with basic idea.
I want to just say it in the simplest possible terms.
Uh,
what is it that we,
first of all,
a portfolio,
let's define that a portfolio is the collection of assets that you have,
financial assets,
tangible assets,
what it's your wealth.
The first and fundamental principle is you care only about the total portfolio.
You don't want to be someone like the fishermen who,
who boasts about one big fish that he caught because it's not,
we're talking about livelihoods.
It's all the fish that you caught.
And so there's nothing to be proud of if you had one big success.
Uh,
so that's the first very basic principle.
You agree with me on that.
So when we say portfolio management,
we mean managing everything that gives you economic benefit.
Okay?
Now underlying our theory is the idea that we measure the outcome of your
investment in your portfolio by the mean of the return on the portfolio and the
variance of the return on the portfolio.
The return of course,
in any given time period is the percentage increase in the portfolio.
Uh,
or it could be a negative number.
It could be a decrease.
Uh,
and the principle is that you want the expected value of the return to be as
high as possible,
given its variance.
And you want the variants of the return on the portfolio to be as low as
possible given the return,
right?
Because a high expected return is a good thing.
You know,
you could say,
I think my ex,
my portfolio has an expected return of 12% that would be better than if it had
an expected return of 10%.
But on the other hand,
you don't want high variance because that's risk.
Uh,
and so both of those matter and in fact,
different people might make different choices about how much risk they're
willing to bear to get a higher expected return.
But ultimately,
uh,
everyone agrees that's the premise here that for the s if it's,
if you're comparing two portfolios with the same variance,
then you want the one with the higher expected return.
And if you're comparing two portfolios with the same expected return,
you want the one with the lower variance.
All right.
Is that clear?
And,
okay,
so let's talk about,
uh,
I wanted to just give it an a very intuitive term.
Suppose we had a lot of different stocks that we could put into a portfolio and
suppose they're all independent of each other.
That means there's no correlation.
We talked about that in lecture too.
There's no correlation between them.
Uh,
and um,
that means that,
uh,
the,
variance and I want to talk about equally weighted portfolio.
So,
uh,
so we're going to have an independent assets.
Okay.
They could be stocks.
Uh,
and each one has a standard deviation of return.
Call that sigma.
Okay.
And let's suppose that all of them are the same.
They all have the same standard deviation and we're going to call
is the expected
return of these assets.
Okay.
Then we have something called the square root rule,
which says that the standard deviation of the portfolio
equals the standard deviation of one of the assets divided by the square root of
n.
When you read this in the back of my making that big enough,
just he just barely,
okay.
So,
uh,
this is a special case though because I've assumed that the assets are
independent of each other,
which isn't usually the case.
Uh,
so it's like an insurance world where people imagine their ensuring people's
lives and they think that their deaths are all independent.
Uh,
I'm transferring this to the portfolio management problem and you can see it's
the same idea.
All right?
So,
uh,
I've,
I've made a very special case that this is the case of equally weighted
portfolio.
So,
uh,
but it's a very important point.
If you see these very simple math that I'm showing up here,
the return on the portfolio
is our,
but the standard deviation of the portfolio is sigma over the square root of n.
So the optimal thing to do if you live in a world like this is to get an as
large as possible and you can reduce the standard deviation of the portfolio
very much.
And there's no cost in terms of expected return.
So in this simple world,
you'd want to make a Ghana a hundred or a thousand or whatever you could,
and if suppose you could find 10,000 independent assets,
then you could drive the uncertainty about the portfolio of practically to zero,
right?
Because the square root of 10,000 is a hundred.
So whatever the standard deviation of the portfolio is,
you would divide it by a hundred and it would become really small.
So if you can find assets that are all have,
that are all independent of each other,
you can reduce the variance of the portfolio very far.
And that's,
that's the basic,
the basic principle of portfolio diversification.
Um,
that's what portfolio managers are supposed to be doing all the time.
Okay.
Uh,
now I want it to be more general than this and talk about the real case in the
real world.
Uh,
we don't have this problem that assets are independent.
They tend,
the different stocks tend to move up and down together.
And so we don't have the ideal world that I just described,
but to some extent we do.
And so we want to think about diversifying in this world.
So,
um,
now I want to talk about,
uh,
farming,
portfolio,
uh,
where the assets are not independent of each other,
but are correlated with each other.
Okay?
Uh,
and uh,
so what I'm going to do now,
let's start out with the case where now it's going to get a little bit more
complicated.
If we allow,
if we drop the independence assumption,
I'm going to drop more than the independence assumption.
I'm going to assume that the assets don't have the same expected return and they
don't have the same expected variance.
Okay?
So I'm going to,
let's do the two asset case.
All right.
And,
uh,
there's,
n equals two,
but not independent.
Okay.
So,
uh,
not independent
or not.
I'm not,
not necessarily independent.
So,
uh,
asset one
yeah.
Has Expected Return r one?
No,
this is different.
I was assuming I'm in it to go that they're all the same.
It has standard,
this is the expectation of the return on asset and one and r two is the
expectation of the return on that.
I'm sorry.
Uh,
Sigma one is the standard deviation
of the return
on asset one.
And we have the same for asset to,
it has an expected return of our two.
It has a,
a,
a standard deviation of return of sigma too.
And those are the inputs into our analysis.
Okay.
One more thing.
We have,
I said they're not independent,
so we want to,
uh,
we have to talk about the,
covariance between the returns.
So we're going to have the covariance between r one and r two,
which you can also call sigma one,
two.
And those are the inputs to our analysis.
And so what we want to do now is compute the mean and variance of the portfolio
or the mean and standard deviation.
Standard deviation is the square root of the variance.
Uh,
four different combinations of the portfolio.
And I'm going to generalize from our simple story even more by saying that,
uh,
let's not assume that we have equally weighted.
So we're going to put x dollars.
Let's say we have $1 to invest.
We can scale it up and down.
It doesn't matter.
But let's say it's $1.
We're going to put x one in asset one
and that leaves behind one minus x one and asset two.
Okay.
Cause we have $1 total.
We're not going to restrict the x one to be a positive number because as you
know and find it or you should know,
you can hold negative quantities of assets.
That's called shorting them.
You can call your broker and say,
I'd like to short stocks number one.
And what will the broker will do is borrow the shares on your behalf and sell
them.
And then,
uh,
you,
you own negative shares.
So we're not going to,
uh,
x one can be anything.
Uh,
and an ex this,
this is x two
equals one minus x one.
So x one plus x two equals one.
Okay,
now we just want to compute what is the uh,
mean and variance of the portfolio.
And that's a simple arithmetic,
uh,
based on what we talked about before.
So I'm going to erase this.
And,
uh,
the,
portfolio,
uh,
mean and variants will depend on x one in a way that if you put,
if you made x,
y equal one,
it would be acid one.
And if you made x one equals zero,
then it will be the same as asset to returns.
But in between if some other number,
it'll be some blend of the,
the the mean and variance of the portfolio will be some blend of the mean and
variants of the two assets.
So the,
um,
the portfolio expected return
is going to be given by the summation.
I equals one to n x of AI
are survive in this case since n equals two,
that's x one r one plus x two are two or that x one r one plus one minus one.
Alright to uh,
uh,
and,
and that that's the expected return on the portfolio and the variance of the
portfolio,
uh,
Sigma squared,
this is the portfolio variance.
That's the square of the standard deviation is equal to x squared sigma one
squared plus x two squared sigma two squared plus two x one x two sigma one too.
And that that's just the formula for the variance of the portfolio,
uh,
as a function of now,
since they have to sum to one,
I can write this as x one squared sigma,
one squared plus one minus x squared,
Sigma two squared plus two x one one minus x one sigma one too.
And so that,
uh,
together traces out,
I,
I can choose any value of x one I want.
It can be any number from minus infinity to plus infinity.
And that shows me then the,
for any value of x one,
I can compute,
uh,
what our is and what Sigma Square it is.
And I can then describe the opportunities I have from investing that depend on
these.
So now one thing to do is to solve,
uh,
ex,
solve the equation for our a four x one.
And I can then,
uh,
we cast the variance in terms of our,
and so that gives us the variance of the portfolio as a function of the expected
return of the portfolio.
Okay.
Uh,
and so can we just solve this for,
uh,
let's solve x one for our,
so I've got,
uh,
this should be excellent.
Then I make a mistake there.
X One hour one.
Um,
so,
uh,
it says that r minus r two is equal to x one,
our one minus R two.
So x one equals r minus r two,
however,
are one minus r two.
And I can substitute this into this equation
and I get the portfolio variance as a function of the portfolio expected returns
are,
and that that's all the basic math that,
that we need.
So if I do that,
I get what's called the frontier for the portfolio.
And I have an example on the screen here,
but it shows other things,
but let me just,
uh,
rather than,
um,
uh,
we're going to show it too many things at once.
Let me just draw it for,
I'll leave that up for now.
But we're moving to that.
Uh,
what we're doing here is we got pull this down
the,
uh,
with two assets.
Uh,
if I plot the expected annual return are and this access and I plot the variance
of the portfolio on this access,
what we have,
I'm sorry,
the standard deviation of the portfolio,
standard deviation
of the portfolio return,
then it tends to look at what it looks,
something like this.
It's a Hyperbola,
uh,
that,
there's a minimum variance portfolio.
Minimum variance with the sigma is as small as possible.
Uh,
and there's a,
then there's many other possible for folios all at lie along this curve.
And so,
uh,
the,
the curve includes points on it which would represent the initial assets.
So for example,
we might have,
uh,
this is asset one
and we might have something here.
This could be asset to,
uh,
depending on,
where the,
uh,
assets expected returns are and the assets,
standard deviations.
You can see that we might be able to do better,
uh,
than,
have a lower variance than either asset.
Um,
equally weighted case that I gave him a minute ago was one where the two assets
had,
we're at the same,
had the same expected return and the same variants,
but this is quite a bit more general.
So that's the expected return efficient portfolio frontier problem.
Uh,
and I wanted to show an example with real data that I computed and that's what's
up on the screen.
Uh,
the pink line takes two assets,
one on stocks and the other is bonds.
Uh,
actually,
um,
you know,
uh,
government bonds and I computed the efficient portfolio frontier for uh,
various,
uh,
it's the efficient portfolio frontier using the formula I just gave you.
So that pink line here,
this pink line here is the efficient portfolio frontier when we have only stocks
and bonds to invest.
And you can see the different points.
I've calculated this using data from 1983 until 2006.
And I computed all of the inputs to those equations that we just saw.
I computed the expected the average return on stocks over that time period.
I computed the average return on bonds over that time period.
These are long term government bonds.
Uh,
and I,
uh,
now these are,
since they're longterm,
they have some uncertainty and variability to them.
And I computed,
uh,
Sigma One Sigma Two r one and r two for those and I plugged it into that
formula,
which we just showed.
And that's the curve that I got out.
It shows the,
uh,
standard,
the standard deviation of the return on the portfolio as a function of the
expected return on the portfolio.
And so I can achieve any combination.
I can achieve any point on that by choosing a,
a,
an allocation of my portfolio.
So at this point right here is on the pink line is,
uh,
a portfolio,
100% bonds.
And so over this time period,
that portfolio had an expected return of something like a little over 9% and had
a stint at standard deviation of a little over 9%.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
a portfolio which is 100% stocks in that portfolio,
is,
uh,
had a,
had a much higher,
uh,
x average return or expected return,
13%,
but it also had a much higher standard deviation of return.
It's about 16%.
So you can see that,
uh,
those are the two raw portfolios that can be an investor only in bonds or an
investor only in stocks.
But I also show on here what some other returns are that are available.
So,
uh,
the minimum variance portfolio is down here.
He said,
that's good.
You got the lowest possible standard deviation of expected return,
and that's 25% stocks and 75% bonds with this sample period.
Uh,
but I can try other portfolios.
This one right here,
I'm pointing to a point on the pink line.
That point right there,
50% stocks,
50% bonds,
okay.
And,
uh,
you can see,
and if you can also go up here,
you can go beyond 100% stocks.
You can have 150% stocks in your portfolio.
That means you'd have a leverage portfolio.
It would be borrowing.
If you had $1 to invest,
you can borrow 50 cents and invest in a dollar 50 worth of stocks,
right?
That would put you out here.
You would have very much more return,
but you'd have more risk borrowing to buy stocks is going to be risky.
Okay.
You could also pick a point down here,
which is more than a hundred percent bonds.
How would you do that?
Well,
you could short the stock market.
You could short 50 cents worth of stocks and buy a 150 cents worth of bonds and
that would put you down here.
Any one of those things as possible.
It's just the simple math that I just showed you.
Okay?
Uh,
do you have any idea what you would like to do it assuming this,
but if you're an investor,
you don't like variance,
right?
And uh,
uh,
so you probably don't want to pick any point down here,
right?
Because,
uh,
you're,
you're not getting anything by picking a point down there because you could have
a better point by just moving up here.
You'd have a higher expected return with no more variance.
It's getting kind of complicated isn't that this we started out with just the
simple idea that you don't want to put all your eggs in one basket and if you
have a lot of independent stocks,
uh,
you would,
want to just weight them equally.
But now you see there's a lot of possibilities and the outcome of your portfolio
choice can be anything along this line.
And I was going to tell you what you want to do except to say you would never
pick a point below the minimum variance portfolio,
right?
Because if you did that,
you would,
um,
you would always be dominated.
You could always find a portfolio that had higher expected return for the same
standard deviation.
So,
uh,
but beyond that,
if you are confined to just stocks and bonds,
it would be a matter of taste.
Where along frontier you would be,
we call it an efficient portfolio frontier.
Uh,
you could,
it'd be anywhere from here to here,
depending on how much you're afraid of risk.
Uh,
and how much do you want expected return.
Now we can also move to three assets and uh,
and in fact any number of assets and the same formula extends to more assets.
And in fact,
I,
uh,
I have it,
suppose we have three assets and we want to compute the efficient portfolio
frontier,
the mean and variants of the portfolio.
Okay.
And so what I have up there on the diagram is calculations I made or the
efficient portfolio frontier with three assets.
So now we have n equals three.
Uh,
and in the,
in the chart it's stocks,
bonds and oil.
Oil is a very important asset.
And so we want to compute what,
uh,
what that,
so we have,
now we have a lots of inputs.
We have others,
but the infants,
they r one r two and r three are the expected returns on the three assets.
Then we have the standard deviations of the returns and the three assets.
And then we have the covariance between the returns on the three assets and
there's three of them,
sigma,
one,
two sigma,
one three and sigma two,
three.
Okay.
Uh,
and uh,
that's what we have to know to compute the efficient portfolio frontier with
three assets.
So to make this picture,
I did that.
I computed the returns on the stocks,
bonds and oil,
uh,
for every year from 1983 and I computed the expect the average returns,
which I take as the expected returns.
I took the standard deviations and I took the covariance.
And these are all formulas.
I just plugged it into formulas that we did in the second lecture.
Okay.
And so then what is the portfolio expected return?
The portfolio expected return.
We have to choose three things.
Now what x one x two and x three x one is the amount that I put into the first
asset x two is the amount that I put into the second asset.
An extra three is the amount I put into the third asset and I'm going to
constrain them to sum to one.
So,
uh,
so the return on the portfolio is x one plus x two or two plus x three are
three.
Uh,
and then the variance of the portfolio,
sigma squared is equal to x squared.
Our Wa,
uh,
stigma,
one
plus x two squared,
I think one,
one squared sigma,
two squared plus x three squared,
Sigma three squared.
And then we have to take account of all of the covariants terms plus two x one x
two sigma,
one two
plus two x one x three sigma,
one three plus two x two x three sigma,
two three.
Okay,
so is that clear?
And that's it.
It seems like a logical extension of that formula to three assets and uh,
you can easily see how to extend it to four or more assets,
right?
It's just a logical extension of that.
So what I did in this diagram is I computed the efficient portfolio frontier and
now it's the Blue Line with three assets.
Okay?
Now,
once you have more than three,
more than two assets,
it might be,
uh,
possible to get points inside the frontier.
But I'm talking here,
this is actually the frontier,
the best possible portfolio consisting of three assets.
And you can see that it dominates the pink line,
right?
The,
when you add another asset,
you do better.
When you have three assets you do better than if you just had to.
And that's because there's more diversification possible with three assets.
Then with two.
And uh,
oil bonds and stocks are all independent,
somewhat independent.
They're not perfectly independent,
but there's someone independent.
And to the extent that they are,
it lowers the variance.
Not You should see that the blue line is better than the pink line because for
any expected return,
the Blue Line is to the left of the pink line,
right?
So for example,
at an annual expected return of 12%,
if I have a portfolio of stocks,
bonds and oil,
I can get a standard deviation of something like 8% on my portfolio.
But if I would find myself just to stocks and bonds,
I would get a much higher standard deviation if following us.
So the general principle of portfolio management is you want to include as many
assets as you can.
You want to get it.
Uh,
if you keep adding assets,
you can do better and better and your portfolio standard deviation.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
you can see some of the points I made along the Blue Line here.
Uh,
this is,
um,
let me see.
Do I have,
uh,
oh,
this is,
um,
this is a portfolio which has all oil and stocks and has no bonds.
Uh,
let's see.
Um,
this portfolio,
the minimum variance portfolio is 9% oil,
27% stocks and 64% bonds.
And those are the many choices you can make.
MMM.
And so the first you see the idea here is that,
uh,
in order to manage portfolios,
what we want to do is calculate these statistics,
which,
uh,
the,
the expected returns on the various assets,
the standard deviations of the very asset.
And you've got another covariances,
uh,
because that affects the variance of the portfolio.
The more they co-vary they move together,
the less they cancel out.
Uh,
uh,
and so the higher the covariances,
the generally the higher you can see from here,
the higher the sigma squared for the portfolio.
And so,
um,
yeah,
so is that clear on,
uh,
it's one more thing that we can do.
I have three assets shown here.
I have stocks,
bonds,
and oil.
Uh,
but I want also to add one more final asset,
we'll call it the riskless asset,
uh,
which is,
the asset.
Long term bonds are somewhat uncertain variable because there long term,
but if we have an annual return that we're looking at,
we can find a completely riskless asset,
which if with an annual return,
it would be a government bond that matures in one year.
All right?
Now,
assuming that we trust the government,
I think the US government has never defaulted on its debt.
We take that as a risk list return.
Okay.
Although it probably has some risks,
but in the way we approximate things in finance,
we take the government as riskless.
And so,
uh,
with the government a expected return,
we want to make that,
uh,
that expected return as a fourth asset.
Uh,
if we could call it r four,
but I'll call it our sub f.
It's a special assets.
So our sub f is the riskless asset.
Okay.
And so what for it?
Uh,
Sigma sub F equals zero.
Okay.
It's like a fourth asset,
but we were using a special feature of this asset that it has no risk.
Okay.
Moreover,
uh,
the correlation,
the covariance between any of these sigma,
one f equal zero,
et Cetera,
it just doesn't have risk to it.
It has no variability.
So if we want to add that asset to the portfolio,
uh,
what it does is it produces an efficient portfolio frontier that is now a
straight line and I show that on the diagram.
Uh,
and so the best possible portfolio that you can get would be points along this
straight line.
Uh,
and that is the final aspect of the efficient,
uh,
portfolio calculations.
Again,
I'm not able to give this as much of a discussion as I would like cause I don't
want to spend too much time on this in the review sections.
I'm hopeful that you're a ta is,
can elaborate on this more,
but there's a very important principle that finally comes out here,
is that you always want to reduce the variance of your portfolio as much as you
can.
And so that means that you want to pick ultimately a point on this.
This,
this line is tangent to the efficient portfolio frontier with all the other
assets in it.
Tangent means that it has the same slope,
it just touches the f the efficient portfolio frontier for risky assets at one
point.
And the slope of the uh,
efficient portfolio frontier including the riskless asset is a straight line
that goes through the tangency point here.
Uh,
and that is the end.
I think that's the end of my mathematics.
Uh,
but what I have shown here is how you calculate your portfolio management.
The way you would go about if you're a portfolio manager is you have to come up
with estimates of the inputs to these formulas.
That means the expected returns,
the standard deviations and the covariances.
You take all the risky assets and you had an analyze them first to get there.
Uh,
you have to do a statistical analysis to get their expected returns,
their variances in their covariances.
Once you've got them together,
then you can compute the efficient portfolio frontier without the riskless
asset.
And then finally,
the final step is to find what is the tangency line that goes through the
riskless rate.
Uh,
it doesn't show it on this chart.
It goes to 5% at a standard deviation of zero.
And uh,
and then it touches the for a risky asset efficient portfolio frontier at one
point.
And then,
uh,
and then from there it goes up above,
in terms of higher expected return for the same variance.
Yeah.
So that's the theory of,
of a efficient portfolio calculation.
Um,
there's something that,
a fundamental principle,
and this is leading us in now to the institutional topic of this course,
is that there's only one tangency portfolio and that portfolio is called the
tangency portfolio.
Uh,
where a line drawn from the,
from the x axis at the risk list rate is tangent to the efficient portfolio
frontier.
Um,
and so the tangency portfolio
is the portfolio that one should hold.
And the tangency portfolio gives rise to what's called the mutual fund theorem
in finance,
which says that
all investors need is a single mutual fund.
Uh,
now I haven't defined mutual fund yet.
A mutual fund is a investment vehicle that allows investors to hold a portfolio.
The theory of mutual funds is nobody is supposed to be holding anything other
than the idea of theory of mutual fund is holding something other than this
tangency portfolio.
So why don't we set up a company that creates a portfolio like that and
investors can buy into that portfolio.
And so what this,
uh,
if my analysis is right,
namely,
if I've got all of the right estimate of the expected returns on stocks,
bonds and oil and the standard deviations and covariances and I've,
and assuming the interest rate is 5%,
which is what I've assumed here,
that this line,
if you go to zero and hits that 5%,
it hits the vertical axis at 5% then everyone should be holding the tangency
portfolio.
And what is the tangency portfolio?
In this case,
it's a 12% oil,
36% stocks and 52% bonds.
Uh,
that's what I got using this sample period.
Some people might disagree with that.
They might not take my estimates.
They might say my sample period was off.
But that's what the theory,
using my data for the sample period that I computed the expected returns and
covariances says one should do.
So the theory says everybody should be investing in these proportions,
uh,
and this theory then,
um,
it doesn't leave any,
uh,
latitude for individual choice except that you can choose which mixture of the
mutual fund and the rest of this asset you want to.
So somebody who is very risk averse could say,
I want to hold only of the riskless asset cause I,
I just don't like any risk at all.
That person I should have maybe included on the diagram,
but that person can get 5% return with no risk.
Somebody else might say,
well,
I want to just hold this point.
I want to hold the tangency portfolio.
That's attractive to me because I could then get a bigger expected return.
I could get almost 12% return per year and I'd sacrifice,
I'd have some standard deviation of like 8% but if that's what I want,
uh,
if I have different tastes about risk,
then,
and that's what I want that then that's the optimal thing to do.
Other people might say,
well,
you know,
I'm really,
uh,
an adventure.
I don't care too much about risk.
I want the much higher return.
Such a person might pick a point up here and that would be a portfolio with a
leveraged portfolio that would be a portfolio where you borrowed at the riskless
rate and you put more than 100% of your money into the tangency portfolio.
So what you could do is say,
borrow 50 cents on your dollar and put 155 cents into a portfolio,
which consisted of 9% oil,
27% stocks in 64% of bonds.
But everyone would do that.
No one would ever hold some other portfolio because you can see that this line
is the lowest.
It's as far you want to get to the left as far as possible.
You want to for any given expected return,
you want to minimize the standard deviation.
So it's the leftmost line and that means that everyone will be holding the same
portfolio.
Uh,
I don't claim that my analysis is profound in the final answer.
I just took some estimates using my data and again,
we could come if someone wanted to argue with this,
they could argue with my estimates of,
of,
of the expected returns of the standard deviations and the covariances.
But not with this theory.
This theory is very rigorous.
So if you,
if you agree with my estimates,
then you should do this.
As an investor,
you should hold only some mixture of this tangency portfolio,
which is 9% oil,
27% stocks,
and 64% bonds.
Do you see what we've got here?
I started out with the equally weighted.
I was talking about stocks,
uh,
about uh,
and stocks that all have the same variance and are all independent of each
other.
But I've dropped that assumption and now I'm going on to assuming that they're
taking account of their dependence on each other,
taking account of their different expected returns and taking account of their
different covariances and variances.
So that's what we've got.
This is a famous framework.
It's the kind of this diagram,
I think the most famous diagram in all of financial theory.
And so it's,
uh,
it's actually the first theoretical diagram.
Uh,
I did it myself using my data,
but it would always looks more or less like this and be slightly different
positions if people use different estimates.
So I actually showed this diagram.
I went to Norway with my colleague,
actually have a couple more pictures here.
Um,
I was,
that's my colleague run heat.
Well,
me and I showed that we're posing in front of the parliament building in Oslo.
We went to Norway,
did discuss,
uh,
the,
with the Norwegian government,
uh,
their portfolio and I,
this is a slide that I showed them.
I showed them the slide that I just showed you,
showing that,
uh,
optimal portfolio.
And then I looked at the Norwegian governments,
uh,
physician.
Uh,
the Norwegian government has pension fund assets and the amount of,
as of 2006,
I've just under 2000 to 2 trillion Norwegian kroner.
Uh,
but they also own North Sea oil.
And if you know that it's kind of divided between the UK and Norway,
Norway is a much smaller population than the UK.
So,
and they have a lot of oil up there.
Uh,
and then in the North Sea.
So as of then I calculated the value of their oil in the North Sea.
Okay.
And that's what I got.
It's worth about,
uh,
35,
3.5 billion Norwegian kroner.
Um,
do you see the difference?
Uh,
in fact,
the assets that the Norwegian government owns is about two thirds oil and one
third,
uh,
government pension fund assets.
Uh,
this government pension ficus in dollars,
it's about a 200 billion.
Uh,
and so it's a huge amount of money that they're managing,
but I was trying to convince them that they should do something to manage their,
uh,
their oil risk because they're way over invested in oil.
Right?
So where are they on the efficient portfolio frontier?
Uh,
actually I can activate
this thing.
Okay.
Uh,
Eh,
they have 64% oil in their portfolio.
Uh,
where does that put them?
Well,
it's,
it's really off the diagram.
The furthest point that I recorded,
it was 28% oil that puts them there.
So if they,
if you wanted to,
where would it be?
It'd be somewhere over there.
You're off the charts.
And so what the Norwegian government is doing wrong is,
uh,
and I,
I,
it was a little bit controversial.
I pointing this out to them.
I ended up in the newspaper the next day.
We're having argued they are way off on their,
on their investment opportunities,
uh,
because oil is such a volatile thing and they've got so much of their assets
tied up in oil.
So I got a good hearing.
We went to the Ministry of Finance and we went to the,
um,
uh,
Noriega's Norges bank,
which is their central bank.
And I think the answer I got from them was,
yes,
you're right.
I never got twice like that.
Something like that.
Uh,
there was,
uh,
a conditional agreement.
Yes,
Norway should manage this oil risk.
Um,
but then,
uh,
there's,
it's politically difficult and that's the problem is that we're not,
we're not able to do our optimal management.
Maybe there's a number of structural problems that prevent them from doing that
and they think maybe that,
no,
I think Norway,
we may be moving that way.
So we'll,
we'll see in the future.
Uh,
I went to the Bank of Mexico.
I tried to convince the,
I met the president of the Bank of Mexico and it's hard to tell them that Mexico
is too reliant on oil,
too much oil.
They have to get rid of their risk.
And I'm going to the Russian Stabilization Fund and mark,
I think I've got an arrangement to meet with them in Moscow and mark.
That would be during the semester.
I'll tell you what reaction I,
I hope I get from the Russians.
Uh,
but,
uh,
yeah,
oil is very important to the Russian economy.
Uh,
and are they managing the risk?
Well,
I bet not a,
I'm going to do a diagram like this,
uh,
for Russia.
Uh,
and the countries that really matter are the ones that,
uh,
the Arabian Gulf countries,
and I was just talking to people at the World Economic Forum about that.
Some of those countries are really reliant on oil and so they really have to do,
they really should do a calculation of a efficient portfolio.
Frontier is one of the lessons of this course is we have a wonderful theory,
but we don't manage it well.
Mostly and I don't mean to be criticizing foreign countries.
The same criticism applies to the United States as well.
We're in a different position.
Where are we on this frontier regarding oil in the United States?
Well,
we don't have much oil relative to the size of our portfolio.
I don't know what present oil reserves in the u s are pretty small.
Uh,
so we're kind of lying somewhere inside maybe on this pink line.
So,
uh,
people in the u s don't have the optimal portfolio either.
So I set up a theoretical framework here and,
um,
I wanted to,
uh,
give you,
I mentioned oil because it seems to make it to me so clear what we're talking
about here.
It's a talking about not getting tied up in risk.
And so I was talking to someone at the World Economic Forum from an,
um,
an Arabian,
uh,
a Persian Gulf country.
And I said,
uh,
um,
all right,
aren't you worried about or worried about reliance on oil?
And he said,
of course we're worried on reliance so much.
Uh,
so much of our GDP and of our government revenues are oil related.
We've seen the price of oil lately move all over the map,
went up to a hundred dollars recently,
and it was just a,
as late as late 1990s,
it was under $20.
And people just don't know where it's going to go.
Uh,
so I think that,
uh,
the,
and,
and these countries are somewhat trying to manage this oil,
but they can't yet get onto the frontier.
And that's assigned to me that,
uh,
that,
um,
uh,
we're not,
we're not there yet.
And we have a lot more to do in finance.
Uh,
so there's one more equation that I wanted to write down and I'm going to not,
uh,
it's,
I'm not going to spend a lot of time explaining this,
uh,
because it's,
um,
uh,
it's gonna,
it's gonna take awhile,
but that this is the equation that,
uh,
that relates to the expected return on an asset.
And in the,
it's so called capital asset pricing model and the capital asset pricing model
in finance,
I'm getting charged.
That's a,
okay.
This is the most famous model in finance,
uh,
and it's abbreviated as the cap m not going to do it justice here.
I'm sorry,
but there's so many,
uh,
in,
in ins and outs of this,
you should really take a econ two 51 who learned this morning.
Uh,
but it,
uh,
it was a mile divided by James Tobin here at Yale,
was the original,
uh,
you've got the original precursors,
but it was more,
uh,
indented by William Sharpe,
John Lintner,
Harry Markowitz.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I'll every one of these except the listener.
I think one of the Nobel Prize winner didn't get it,
did he?
I think he died too young.
That's the four one of the misfortunes of living.
Um,
I did that.
I say that right.
One of the misfortunes of scholarship,
you have to live long enough to get your accolades.
Uh,
but the capital asset pricing model,
and this is a critical,
assumes everyone
is rational
and,
and holds the tangency portfolio.
So,
uh,
that is a wild assumption,
but it's fun to make,
uh,
because,
I know pretty well,
I know very well how that people aren't doing this.
Uh,
and they have lots of maybe good read.
Maybe it's not because they're irrational,
it's that their political or they're,
um,
they're constrained by tradition or laws or regulations in all sorts of things,
but they're not holding the mark tangency portfolio.
But it's a beautiful theory,
uh,
to assume,
see what would happen if they did.
That would mean that everybody is holding that same portfolio of risky assets
and nobody is different.
Uh,
they only differ in how,
what proportions they hold.
The rescue put the tangency portfolio.
Uh,
and sorry,
it implies that the tangency portfolio,
okay.
Has to equal the,
uh,
actual market portfolio.
And that means then
it's a very simple invocation of the theory.
In my diagram I said that the tangency portfolio,
all right,
estimated at the tangency portfolio is 9% oil,
27% stocks and 64% bonds.
So for all doing that,
then that has to be what the outstanding is.
We can,
if we're all holding the same portfolio,
that has to be the,
the total.
So that would mean that 9% of all wealth is stocks.
A 27% of all [inaudible] is oil.
27% of our wealth has stock and a 64% of those bonds.
And so,
uh,
if you accept my estimates and you accept the capital asset pricing model,
that would have to be true.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't want to make too much of my estimates because different people,
but estimate these things in different ways.
Um,
but that's the theory.
The theory says that the Tangency portfolio equals the after my portfolio.
And then that gives us the,
uh,
the famous equate.
And I'm not going to derive this,
but there is the most famous equation in finance says,
can you read that?
That's our survive.
The expected return on the
asset is equal to the riskless rate plus something called the Beta for the
[inaudible] asset times the expected return on the market minus the risk list.
Right.
Uh,
now again,
not going to spend much time on this,
but,
uh,
the,
the Beta of the IFE asset is the regression coefficient.
When you regress the return on the IFE asset and the return of the market
portfolio and our Savannah is the expected return,
um,
the market portfolio.
Yeah.
Which is the portfolio of all assets.
The market portfolio is if you took all the stocks and bonds and Arielle and
real estate,
anything that's available to invest in,
in the whole world,
put them all together in one portfolio.
Uh,
it's the world portfolio,
it's everything.
And we compute the expected return on that portfolio.
Uh,
uh,
that's our Sebam.
Okay.
And also we need to know how much individual stocks are correlated with what
with our Savannah.
We measured that by the regression coefficient.
So,
uh,
the Beta of a stock is how much it reacts to movements in the market portfolio.
If Beta equals one,
it means that if the market portfolio goes up 10% in value,
then yeah,
this asset also goes up 10% in value.
If Beta is two,
it means that if the,
um,
uh,
it's a market goes up 10% in value of the stock tends to go up 20% in value and
so on.
So,
uh,
these are the basic theoretical structure is that you answered that they need
for the problem set,
uh,
the first problem set.
So the first problem is that I guess you've,
you can turn in your first problem set here and,
uh,
before you leave,
because it was due today.
The second problems that is about this model.
And so I realize I've given you some difficult mathematics,
but,
um,
it's not that difficult actually,
but I kind of went through it quickly.
Uh,
so,
uh,
w we are setting up,
are you,
um,
you have already gotten email and you've talked to the,
about setting up your review session.
So it keeps getting caught here.
Uh,
so I have a few more minutes here.
So,
uh,
what I wanted to,
I wanted to talk about,
um,
uh,
Jeremy Siegel's book and the equity premium puzzle,
underlying this analysis.
Uh,
we,
we have estimates of the expected returns on
assets,
notably the expected returns on stocks and bonds.
Um,
and,
uh,
so,
Jeremy Siegel in his book,
which is a sign for this course,
uh,
it's really emphasizing this capital asset pricing model,
emphasizing the kind of efficient portfolio frontier calculations that I've
done.
And so what a seagull emphasize the book is really about this.
He talks about what is the expected return of stocks and what is the expected
return of bonds and so on.
So,
uh,
we're going to call asset one stocks in the US and we're going to call it asset
to bonds.
Okay.
And so he estimates for his purposes and he shows you the calculations of the
efficient portfolio frontier.
But I wanted to just talk a little bit about his estimate.
He has data for a very long time period.
1802 to 2006.
Uh,
okay.
For the u s all right.
Uh,
and um,
okay.
Uh,
over that very long time interval,
um,
the expected return,
uh,
that,
we got four a stocks was um,
uh,
6.8% a year in real terms.
This is real inflation corrected.
Yeah.
Whereas for bonds,
it was a over this whole time periods,
2.8% a year real
okay.
And then he also compute sigma one and sigma two and sigma one too.
But I'm not going to talk about that right now.
The real interest.
And so then he compared to the efficient portfolio frontier,
now he's using a much longer sample than I did.
And so he's not going to get this tangency portfolio that I did.
The thing that is very interesting that he finds is the difference 4% between
the historical real return on stocks and the historical real return on bonds.
And so this is called the equity premium.
Actually,
I should take that.
This is really our sub f.
Uh,
he shows all three.
our sub F that I'm reporting is the riskless rate.
Uh,
there's also,
if you look at a table one in chapter one,
it shows a Arwan one stocks are too long term bonds.
And these are short term that I'm recording here.
So the equity premium is the,
this short term 2.8% is the risk list return historically for a period of a
almost 200 years.
And this is the return on stocks for a period of almost 200 years.
So stocks have paid 4% more a year over this incredibly long time period than
short term bonds.
Uh,
also they paid much more than long term.
Well,
it's not so different than me.
This,
I don't have the data in front of me.
So,
uh,
but let's emphasize the difference between r one and r.
F it surprises many people that stocks have paid such an enormous premium over,
uh,
over the,
return on short term debt.
Uh,
and so the theme of Siegel's book,
uh,
is,
can we believe this?
I mean,
do you really,
you might wonder,
I aren't people missing something if,
uh,
if the excess return is so high of,
of stocks over short term bonds,
uh,
why would anyone not just hold a lot of really large number of stocks?
So that's the theme of his book and His book is that his conclusion is that he
largely believes that this is true,
uh,
that the returns that we have seen in the u s in the stock market,
I have exceeded those of other,
uh,
assets,
by,
uh,
quite a substantial margin.
And that that means he is calculations are very different than the ones I have
because he has a much longer sample period.
I was using only from eight,
1983 to the present.
For him,
the optimal portfolio should be very heavily into stocks and this is a
controversial view,
but that is the view that he advances in the book.
And I think it's a very interesting analysis.
Uh,
uh,
so what it means then is that the
optimal portfolio,
it should not be the one I show there,
but she'd be one that's very heavily into stocks.
And,
um,
this is,
uh,
I,
I'm sure I hear us data,
but a seagull also argues in the latest edition,
uh,
that the equity premium is also high
for advanced countries over the whole world.
So if you look at his book,
uh,
and again,
in the first chapter he gives a list of countries.
It's based on an analysis that,
uh,
some other that the professor is Dimson Marsh and Stanton,
used in their book 2002 book.
But,
uh,
they show the expected return on stocks versus bonds or short term debt for
a whole range of countries.
And in every one of these countries since 19,
uh,
1901,
there has been a very high equity premium.
So,
um,
I'll let you read Segal and his discussion of this possibility.
But I think that what I want to get now is not necessarily any agreement on
whether you believe that there's such a high excess return for stock.
But I just want you to understand the basic framework.
So the first problem set,
uh,
asked you to manipulate the model that I just presented.
Uh,
the model of how you form portfolios and the model of,
uh,
of,
um,
the capital asset pricing model.
And I have one final question just about the mutual fund industry.
The mutual fund industry is supposedly according to theory doing this for you.
So the ideal thing would be that the mutual fund does these calculations and it
puts it all together for you,
at least in some approximate sense.
That's what they are doing.
Uh,
and so I asked you in the final question to just get a couple of websites,
the Federal Reserve and the ICI,
which is a mutual fund industry,
a website and a rate,
a little bit,
a couple of paragraphs about what this industry is really,
uh,
achieving,
or how it's Chen,
how it's trending.
Okay.
And so next Wednesday,
where there's three lectures this week,
uh,
Wednesday will be about the insurance industry and I'll see you in two days.
Then.